simplify the expression 18x to the
fourth minus 3x squared plus 6x minus 4
all of that over 6x so there's a couple
of ways to think about them they're all
really equivalent you can really just
view this up here as being the exact
same thing as
x to the fourth
over a 6x
plus negative 3x squared over 6x or you
could say minus 3x squared over 6x
plus 6x
over 6x
minus 4 over 6x now there's a couple of
ways to think about it one is i just
kind of decompose this numerator up here
if i just had a bunch of stuff a plus b
plus c
over d that's clearly equal to a over d
plus b over d
plus c over d
or maybe not so clearly but hopefully
that helps clarify another way to think
about it is kind of like you're
distributing the division if i'm if i if
i divide a whole expression by something
that's equivalent to dividing each of
the terms by that something the other
way to think about it the other way to
think about it is that we're multiplying
this entire expression so this is the
same thing as 1 over 6 x
times this entire thing times 18 x to
the fourth minus 3x squared plus 6x
minus 4. and so here this would just be
the straight distributive property to
get to this whatever seems to make sense
for you they're all equivalent they're
all logical good things to do to
simplify this thing now once you have it
here now we just have a bunch of
monomials that we're just dividing by 6x
and here we can just use exponent
properties this first one over here we
can take the coefficients and divide
them 18 divided by 6
is 3
and then you have
x to the fourth divided by x to the well
they don't tell us but if it's just an x
that's the same thing as x to the first
power so it's x to the fourth divided by
x to the first that's going to be x to
the four minus one power or x to the
third power
then we have this coefficient over here
or these coefficients we have negative 3
divided by 6. so i'm going to do this
part next negative 3 divided by 6 is
negative 1 half
and then you have
x squared divided by x we already know
that x is the same thing as x to the
first so that's going to be x to the
2 minus 1 power which is just 1 or i
could just leave it as an x right there
then we have
then we have these coefficients 6
divided by 6 well that's just 1
so i could just well i'll write it i
could write a 1 here let me just write
the 1 here because we said 2 minus 1 is
1. and then x divided by x is x to the
first over x to the first to give you
some two ways anything divided by
anything is just one or you could view
it as
x to the one divided by x to the one is
going to be x to the one minus one which
is x to the zero which is also equal to
1 either way you you know how to do this
before you even learn that exponent
property because x divided by x is 1
and then assuming x does not equal 0.
and then finally and we kind of have to
assume x doesn't equal 0 in this whole
thing otherwise we would be dividing by
zero and then finally we have four over
six x and there's a couple of ways to
think about it so the simplest way is
both four four negative four let me do
it
negative four over six is the same thing
as negative two thirds just simplify
that fraction and we're multiplying that
times one over x and so we could cut we
could multiply that times one over x so
we could do this four times one over x
another way to think about it is you
could have viewed this 4 is being
multiplied by x to the 0 power and this
being x to the first power and then when
you tried to simplify it using your
exponent properties you would have well
that would be x to the 0 minus 1 power
which is x to the negative 1 power so we
could have written an x to the negative
1 here but x to the negative 1 is the
exact same thing as 1 over x and so
let's just write our answer completely
simplified so it's going to be 3
x to the third
minus one half x
plus one because this thing right here
is just one so plus
plus one
and then minus
two times one in the numerator over
three times x in the denominator and we
are done or we could write this
depending on what you consider more
simplified this last term right here
could also be written in minus two
thirds
x to the negative one but if you don't
want a negative exponent you could write
it like that